bonjour antoine alors que sait-on de
plus sur cette affaire
oui sergei four galles est soupçonné de
meurtres et tentatives de meurtres
contre des chefs d'entreprises dans des
affaires qui remontent à 2004 et 2005 à
l'époque il était lui même chef
d'entreprise dans le secteur du bois
puis celui de la ferraille en plus de
l'arrestation du gouverneur quatre
membres du groupe criminel supposés ont
également été interpellés toujours dans
cette région de l'extrême orient de la
russie je vous propose d'écouter
à ce sujet la porte-parole du comité
d'enquêté de la fédération de russie
le comité d'enquêté le service fédéral
de sécurité de la fédération de russie
ont arrêté le gouverneur du craj de
khabarovsk sergei fourgue al des
poursuites pénales ont été engagées
contre lui suite à un travail long et
minutieux effectué par le comité d'
enquêtes ces dernières années et dont le
but était d'enquêter sur les crimes
particulièrement graves commis en 2004
2005 par un groupe criminel organisé
dans le crash de khabarovsk ainsi que
dans l'oblast de l'amour selon l'
enquête sergei furgala était
l'organisateur de tentative de meurtre
et de meurtre d'un certain nombre
d'entrepreneurs galfond galles était
devenu gouverneur en 2018 un peu à la
surprise générale en battant au passage
le candidat de russie unie le parti de
la majorité mais avec cette enquête dont
il est l'objet
vladimir poutine risque maintenant très
probablement de le de le destituer de
lui de lui retirer son poste de
gouverneur d'après la douma il était
sergei forgan était dans le collimateur
de la justice déjà depuis de nombreuses
années et c'est grâce uniquement grâce à
de nouveaux éléments en particulier des
témoignages qu'il a finalement pu être
inculpé une inculpation que le principal
intéressé rejette on vient de
l'apprendre il a décidé de plaider non
coupable face aux chefs d'accusation qui
lui ont été présentés c'est maintenant à
moscou que l' enquête continue afin de
voir si d'autres crimes n'ont pas été
commis à noter que dans cette région
très éloignée de moscou dans le craj de
khabarovsk hisser son prédécesseur fait
lui aussi
le prédécesseur de sergei de sergei four
galles fait lui aussi l'objet de
poursuites judiciaires mais lui pour des
faits de détournement de fonds merci
antoine pour toutes ces précisions